alright guys we're here with Rahul thank
you so much sir I'm excited by this
conversation because you guys have a
working product which is somewhat rare
and you're one of the first founders
with actual token that we've had on the
podcast so welcome thank you thanks for
having me for sure alright uh how about
just a quick background on you
personally alright how do you get to to
crypto in eSports sure well I've been a
long time entrepreneur in the video game
space I actually started the the world's
first PC gaming hardware manufacturer we
used to build pcs specific to play video
games on and I ended up selling it to HP
many years later and so I've been in the
gaming space for a long time I got
involved with a lot of startups I'm you
know on the board of advisor and early
shareholder and razor I've been you know
involved in like VR and AR companies and
things like that and I ended up joining
Microsoft after selling to HP and I I
was at Microsoft for a few years started
Microsoft ventures and we would invest
in companies and we set up startup
accelerators around the world and at
that time I was really looking at the
eSports base very closely and one of the
companies that we invested in at
Microsoft was a video game community
company myself and the CEO got along
really well and I decided that in 2014
I'm leaving Microsoft to start unicorn
with him so that's what we did awesome
let's talk about eSports in general
because I think it's very very
underrated outside of maybe the tech
community and specifically the esports
thing like how big is this right sure so
eSports is is actually the fastest
growing sport right now it's huge
there's there's literally hundreds of
millions of fans around the world that
that watch people play professional like
professional play video games
effectively so it's like watching the
NFL but you're you're actually watching
people play like League of Legends or
dota or something like that and it is it
is it's it's massive it's it's it's
popular all around
world you know we we have I have some
videos like we actually have a team that
we assembled they're the most popular
eSports team in Germany they're also one
of the best csgo teams in the world
they're called b IG and there was an
event that that they did recently and
there was a you know huge stadium in in
germany that was sold out there was like
20,000 people in the arena it looked
like a World Cup event and if we had
20,000 jerseys with the name on it they
would have bought them like it was that
nuts that's awesome so yeah it is a very
very big space and and not only does it
involve watching games but it also
involves people who who watch players
there's a huge you know there's there's
a lot of fan and community building in
the space and there's also the
competitive side of actually playing
video games competitively against people
as well yourself so yeah got it
and when we talk about this right what
is the draw of watching people play
video games is it just that so many
people play the games and then they get
a watch people who are better than them
or or like what is actually you know
inspiring people to spend the time to
watch other people play the video so
great question it's it's like you know
if you're a huge fan of let's say you're
a fan of the NFL right and you love to
watch the Seahawks play for example and
like imagine you know you can watch the
game and you can be excited about
Russell Wilson throw in a you know a
touchdown or whatever that sort of thing
but imagine then being able to watch
Russell Wilson practice in his backyard
for six hours while talking to you on
the camera right that level of
engagement you get in eSports you just
don't get in any other sport these these
guys will go home they'll stream and and
they'll stream themselves playing games
that are highly complex highly detailed
that you know the the amount of betting
markets that we can create in one a
sport matches is much higher than you
can do on a traditional sport mhm so
there's a lot of like thinking that goes
into it and then watching these guys
play they're super entertaining some of
them are just amazing like I watch this
I watch one streamer almost daily his
name is bunny foo-foo I watch him for
about an hour it was with the name bunny
foo-foo
amazing he's he's a league of Legends
player but he's he's super funny and and
you know just if you know the game and
how
flex that actually is just watching in
plays it's kind of masterful it's really
neat and and so you watch them for a
while and then you want to see if you
can do that so you can just load up the
game and start playing it yourself
that's sort of the allure and it's it's
it's a space where you know literally
hundreds of millions of people do this
is why twitch is so popular right why
YouTube gaming exists it's why every
major publisher aspires now to have you
know a true eSport title because the
amount of revenue that they can generate
from just the events the viewership the
play the skins all of that stuff is just
a it's it's incredible you know how how
big these companies are getting
absolutely and so let's talk about these
eSport teams right because I think that
watching somebody at home you know while
they're playing and they're streaming
live it is one thing because you get
kind of that practice element but then a
lot of these players end up going and
joining a professional team walk us
through like do they all live together
do they train together is there like
practice sessions and then games where
the games held like just what does that
professional eSports community look like
yet so there's there's a few really
popular eSports out there there's League
of Legends there's dota 2 there's csgo
those are so the big ones fortnight is
pretty popular but in terms of the team
games it's the first three that I
mentioned and you know it it's it's it's
it's very interesting because you'll
have you'll have these players go into a
team house they stay in a team house
there's coaches there's there's you know
like therapists they have they have
people that actually work with them on
you know the physical activity they work
with them on psychology like there's a
sports psychologists on the team there's
there's you know a couple of different
types of coaches on the team and they
they literally play games all day long
and they train all day long to be the
best at what they do and that's those
typical eSport games and then now you've
got the NBA for example coming into
eSports and they're really investing
heavily into it because they they notice
a big trend like in traditional sports
if you just look at traditional sports
as a whole start with say the the PGA
Tour
the average PGA Tour fan is 79 years old
right the average major league baseball
fan is 57
years old Wow right these guys are
getting older and everyday you know a
major league baseball fan and a PGA Tour
fan you know passes away and there's
like for eSports fans born because
people start playing video games at a
much younger age than what they used to
play right and so the NBA is looking at
this and thinking okay we want to get
younger people into the arena and we
want to capture their attention so they
actually started creating eSport teams
and they had a full combine and they
they have houses they have training
facilities I mean these are like
world-class that's the NBA 2k league
your champion 2k league I'm talking
about
so I actually know somebody who was
coaching one of these teams and it was
fascinating to hear him talk about not
only what goes into it in terms of
playing but these things you're talking
about right the the practice sessions
the drafting of players you know this is
very analogous to the way that non
eSport games work writer teams yeah just
like the NFL or MBA has these these
combines drafts etc how is this evolving
right because of really my understanding
is that most of this originally was
occurring internationally and now is
becoming popular in the u.s. like it's
almost gone reversed for most people in
the u.s. that it was popular somewhere
else and now here actually Anthony I you
know not to correct you but literally
you disagree I want to hear you disagree
like I'll disagree in the sense that it
was discovered here because people
weren't paying attention to it right
like I don't know if it's a cultural
thing maybe people just don't pay
attention to what their kids are doing
as much here as they do say in South
Korea mhm but but it's really popular
here and it's always been quite popular
here it's just not it hasn't been as
public here because typically people
here they'll look at things like if
something needs to be mainstream it has
to be on TV for example right that's the
old way of looking at things you know
the reality is eSports doesn't need to
be on TV TV needs eSports on TV if cable
cutting is to stop right but we all know
cable cutting is happening and it you
know twitch is where where people are
sort of gathering YouTube is where
they're gathering YouTube TV is exists
for a reason and these trends are
happening as you know sort of as we
speak so you know when I was at
Microsoft yeah you know I was doing a
lot of interesting things with different
startups and we were doing
trend-spotting
one of the things we learned was that
there was hundreds of millions of people
that were watching other people play
video games which is really kind of
strange when you think about it if
you're if you're somebody from the
outside looking in you're like whoa what
what is this and most of these people
were playing on the Microsoft platform
they were playing on Windows or Xbox
right but mostly Windows so so imagine
there's like two people at Microsoft
that know what's going on and everybody
else has no clue that all these people
are actually watching these games right
and my son was the one who really got me
into these games he said like dad you
know you started voodooed many years ago
you gotta quit Microsoft and go back
into gaming and really look at what
happened to eSports because when I was
doing it it was just competitive gaming
it wasn't as popular and I started to
spend time in his world and I think it's
really just spending time with your kids
and seeing you know where the trends are
actually going for sure let me ask this
question how do you think the cord
cutting and the kind of the streaming
etc will impact kind of in-person
attendance and the reason why I asked
this is I remember there was this photo
that kind of went semi viral
it's the Staples Center everyone's on
their phone and well I want everyone's
on their phone and they have the big
screens up and you know when you go to
like a NBA game for example there's a
court and there's kind of movement
people are running around everything but
everyone went to the Staples Center and
it it appeared I've never been right so
this is all kind of my understanding of
it the players were down in the in the
center of the arena and they were
playing and they were kind of lined up
you know each team on each side but most
of the fans were not watching the
players they were actually staring at
the screen of the game of which the
players were playing so they went in
person to the Staples Center I mean
there were tens of thousands of people
there and they're all watching a screen
is one is that accurate and then two is
do you think that the streaming live I
can almost get that same experience at
home will that take away from those
imperfect in-person experiences no you
see the difference between and this is
what's fascinating about eSports is
these are these are not like three-hour
events these are multi-day events you
know that the last international the
dota 2 international had a 24 million
dollar prize pool and it was a multi-day
event so people would pay $300 for a
weekend ticket and they might pay a
couple hundred dollars for a weekday
ticket so they go there for multiple
days and what's up what's amazing about
eSports is I promise you you walk into
an
Sports Arena and you watch those people
are fixated on the action in the game
which means you actually have to watch
the screens but they're watching the
players and they're not on their devices
at all like they're because there's just
so much going on in the game that they
just want to focus on what's happening
in the game so you know it it's it sort
of goes back to one of the hypothesis
with with the NBA was that young people
don't have the attention span to spend
three hours inside the arena so what are
we gonna do it attract young people and
they're wrong you know these guys will
spend nine hours watching eSports you
know like full-on because they actually
care about it and there's just a lot of
detail happening in the game so so so
going back to you know the idea of a
second screen experience unicorn we
actually created a we have a lot of
people in in the betting business who
don't understand eSports right okay
before you go on guess let's talk about
unicorns specifically and what you guys
are doing I'm sure we get in too so give
us some background on unicorn and kind
of what you guys are doing and then we
can talk about the product and Shirley
did sure so we're unicorn is effectively
the eSports bookmaker but we're much
bigger than that you know a typical
betting company is just a is you know
they'll have odds and they'll put odds
up and people will bet you know against
lines and things like that
unicorn it's a fan first betting company
we were founded in 2014 we're venture
backed you know we had investment from
Ashton Kutcher Mark Cuban Elisabeth
Murdoch Shari redstone like a bunch of
really great investors came into unicorn
when we first started and where we are
sitting at the intersection of eSports
and video games regulated gambling and
blockchain and and it's it's it's a
really neat space because you know we're
building the most comprehensive sports
book for eSports in the world where you
can bet on lines but we also have a
scale betting product the neat thing
about eSports is you can have you can
monetize it in many different ways but
it's truly a skill like if you play
League of Legends right you're it's your
skill that you're playing right and
we've come up with a way for us to put
odds on your chances of winning a game
how do you do that and so yeah so in
2015 we created a coin called the unit
coin
and we did it because we wanted to test
out new betting markets we weren't
licensed in every market around the
world obviously we only had a couple of
licenses because one of our investors is
the largest betting company in Australia
and they they let us get a license in
Australia and the Isle of Man that we
could work with them just to just to
test the efficacy of our sports book but
there's people in the US there's people
in Korea there's people like all over
the place I wanted to use the platform
so we created the unit coin as a free
token that people could earn and they
could use it on the platform it couldn't
be bought or sold but it could be used
for jackpots for skins and you know
other things sort of like digital point
just additional points yeah but but you
know we created it to sort of test out
new bedding products and things like
that and at the same time what happens
is customers come to our platform they
connect their League of Legends account
or they connect their their dota or
their csgo rocket league they you can
connect your rock you know your your
gaming account to our platform even
fortnight and you earn tokens well as
you play and win games right okay and
then and you're in these tokens and you
can use them for different things on the
platform but what we do then is once
you're connected we can start collecting
data on gameplay you know game dynamics
and things like that and we start
building we started to really hone our
odds bet our odds making skills right
and so so so not only do we create
amazing odds on just all this the
professional matches out there we now
can create odds on individuals matches
and the reason we did that was because
we know that if people want to bet on
themselves they don't want to wait for
someone else to bet again it's like if I
want to bet you know on League of
Legends I don't want to wait for you to
play against me because then it's like
I'm waiting there and you know who knows
if you're gonna bet or not right I want
to do it so I can just bet on myself and
that's what we did so so we made it
possible for people to bet on themselves
in the game and then play the game and
then it and we put odds on their chances
of doing certain things like for me if I
play fortnight I have a 15 to 1 you know
odds of being one and 100 right so I get
better 100 bucks and you know when $1500
essentially on a game like that and
that's that's how we do it and then and
then so so as I said unicorn does scale
bedding and spectator bedding we we are
a community first company so like I'm a
big believer that you know if you want
to build a real brand you have
to have a community you have to have a
fanbase you know I think about Apple I
think about Ferrari
you know Tesla these are these are
companies that actually have fans that
evangelize and love their product so we
create content the ESPN would around
eSports we also have a team so as I
mentioned I mentioned Vig we have a
tournament platform where people can
create their own tournaments we run
events at the MGM Grand in Las Vegas
every week we you know and then and then
we have these these you know these cool
bedding products that we've created and
the one thing I was going to mention to
you about that you know the spectator
thing is we created a bingo game where
you could be watching a match and it
auto populates with all the live data in
the game like if you're watching csgo
for example it'll be like you know bomb
planted or first kill or you know that's
something on the bingo card right and
and it and it populates live so it's
sort of an onboarding for people who
don't understand the eSports how to play
it it you know one of the things I've
always caught my attention about eSports
I was in Nigeria of all places this may
be two years ago now and they have these
betting houses right so basically people
in the local community will go into this
you know building and they will make
bets it'll bring cash and they'll you
know I know whatever rent no and they'll
bet on these different soccer games or
whatever it is but when my friend and I
went in we were trying to you know
understand the community and the culture
and all stuff and so the the gentleman
who was taking us around took a Senate
and was explaining all this to us and I
saw a game playing on on the television
but it wasn't humans it was it look like
a video game and I looked around I
didn't see anyone playing the game but
it was obviously playing and so I asked
the guy so you know what's going on
there oh those are the simulated games I
said what you mean the simulated games
he goes well what can happen is if
there's no live games being played
anywhere in the world and you don't want
to bet on any of the upcoming games
actually 24 hours a day I think it was
there's these simulated games that play
on the screen and you can actually bet
on who's gonna win the simulated game
you're not in control right so you don't
have the ability to play you don't know
who is playing there's no human on the
other side it's literally a simulated
video game
but people are making bets on it and so
I ask them you know how popular is that
because it might even be more popular
than some of the games it's very popular
and so it was shocking to me how that
was a version of eSports to you know to
a degree but there wasn't even anyone
playing yeah imagine so as I mentioned
tab Corp is one of our investors right
and they're the largest there are 14
billion dollar wagering company based in
Australia they have these these
terminals where you can walk up horse
betting is huge in Australia but they
have these terminals where you can walk
up and you watch like digital horses
race it's like a 24-hour betting we're
applying that thinking to eSports and
we're releasing a product in the next
three months that will allow people to
you know to do something similar a money
I can't get into too much detail but
basically the idea is that right now
that we cover a lot of different matches
like there's thousands of markets that
you can bet on on our product but but
the more markets you have the more
products you have the the more likely
people are Tibetan in different regions
and Fisher that and given our expansion
that we're in the middle of that's
really important to us so that type of
betting that 24-hour betting is really
really key and and as you said what you
saw was like a version resource but not
really but imagine if it were games that
people were familiar with that you can
bet on absolutely
why is like Madden right so the NFL
version of videogame why is that not as
popular in the eSports world as like
let's say the League of Legends or
fortnight or one of those yeah it's it's
a really good question so that's like a
that's like a sort of a mainstream way
of looking at it right you think about
you know like Madden NBA 2k you know how
do these things become more you know I
asked I asked because my brothers and I
spent our entire childhood every member
who was good yeah so so let me just
explain the the the ecosystem really
quickly the games like dota and League
of Legends like you know csgo
high-functioning players are tend to be
great collaborators they tend to be they
tend to work well under pressure they
tend to be really [ __ ] smart like
really good at math they also they also
can you know can make you know great to
sit like quick decisions and be really
good leaders this is why many
universities are actually
offering scholarships now and in fact
this year you'll see Ivy League
universities offering scholarships for
top players because they want those type
of students in their schools they these
are these are the best students that you
could possibly get who play League of
Legends or dota at the highest levels I
mean it is a very difficult game to play
and I promise you anybody who plays at a
high elo is super smart right it get
games like like NBA and and and you know
Madden and things like that these are
sort of these were kind of one player
games right there were kind of one
player competitive games where you play
against you know each other the the
league's are starting so NBA 2k is a
good start because they actually have
team team play and team play offers a
different dynamic than like a single
one-on-one play FIFA has eSports league
now and so but they're they they have
like one or two players per team so it's
it's something that they're starting to
build and they're trying to turn it into
you know something that it's currently
not but it will it will eventually get
there it'll eventually be popular
amongst a certain audience the thing is
though I believe that the reason these
other games are so much more popular is
just because of the complexities and the
you know all the variances that happen
within the game itself interesting where
do you think he sports goes right so
I've heard and I've actually tweeted
this that eSports will be more popular
than the NFL
yes I'm point in the future right and
and and I think it's just laws law of
large numbers global audience right kind
of trends etc but where do you think it
goes in terms of in the United States
how does this evolve do we literally see
you know the traditional sports giving
way to eSports and it's like a binary
one has to lose and one has to win do
they coexist does ESPN all of a sudden
start covering eSports right like how
does this play out so ESPN is covering
eSports now right the the the the
question is like where does it go I
think I think eSports can coexist with
traditional sports I think for example
you could say unicorn right now is an
eSports only company ok I'd in the
future you could say that we're eSports
first and we'll start to look at other
sports that are eSports friendly for
example but to me if you really want me
to paint the future of where eSports is
going I'm somebody who I heavily
invested in a
in a VR AR company based in Canada
called Ravana they just got bought by
Apple recently but but what they were
working on was really compelling so so
they had a headset that you'd wear like
an oculus right but the difference
between this and the oculus was this
supported full VR but it also had
cameras on it so you could do AR with it
as well
now what was unique about it and the
reason Apple bought them was you could
be wearing it in this room and I could
throw a football at you across the room
and you'd catch the ball
right because the latency was just like
near zero now now there's these arenas
that you can go until we can play like
laser tag for adults basically there's a
there's one in Seattle called virtual
sports you were vest you walk around
with a with a fake gun with articulating
feedback there's sensors on your you
know on your head on the vest and then
there's TVs everywhere with like data on
what's happening in the game and you're
running around you're playing laser tag
and you know they they have different
games they have captured the flag you
know it's team-based it's really fun now
imagine that with with with AR like
you're wearing era goggles now and now
you're being dropped into a map so now
you're playing like real-life Call of
Duty against other players and then
there's people watching on the top that
are placing bets on the action that to
me is sort of the future of eSports
where you have a blend of physical and
virtual worlds what's the timeline for
that to happen it's it's sort of
happening like it's coming together now
but I would say within five years we'll
start to see that in a you know in a
bigger way really yeah and do you think
in that scenario what's holding us back
is like people's desire to do that do
you think it's the technology right so
actually like the a our goggles
themselves like why hasn't happened
already the technology the technology
definitely has to be there and also you
know it's it's it's like it's like a
process right I mean these things
develop over time they sort of they come
out of nowhere people are like where did
this come from in the first place
well you know when people say like how
or how is it that hundreds of millions
of people are watching these games and I
didn't know about it well it's because
you're in a different world like you're
a different generation right you didn't
know because you're too busy watching
ESPN on TV rather than looking at what
your kids are watching on twitch right
and once you once you sort of immerse
yourself on that world you can start to
see where things are going and I think
that's just you know the reality is it's
sort of how
opening today but it's happening in in
ways that are maybe not as obvious to
some people got it let's talk about the
company and kind of this token that you
guys have Wrexham I'm really fascinated
by people who create tokens that have a
working product and they use it as an
incentive right so you to either drive
users drive actions you know this isn't
something that's new right we've been
using streaks badges points you know
kind of the whole nine yards as digital
assets or digital products for you know
incentivizing behavior for a long time
right what you did was you basically
created a token that would allow
somebody to wager quota code value right
although it wasn't accepted currency it
was a value on the on the platform when
you first started was it based on the
blockchain was it not based on the
blockchain so when we first started no
was not based on a blockchain okay but
what happened was we were in the middle
of getting our license in Malta and and
we knew that we were just about to get
her license in Malta for Fiat betting
right and I put a call out to
ambassadors because we needed to open up
a couple of bank accounts in Europe and
I don't know you know if you've ever
tried to open up a bank account in
Europe but it's a real nightmare
especially being in a highly regulated
business like ours so I put a call out
to our investors and I said hey we need
to open up some banks in Europe can you
introduce us and within two minutes I
got an email from Mark Cuban who said
are you guys looking at blockchain and
this was like in late 2015 and it said
no not really not yet and he said well
you really should you know it's a future
of Commerce there's a lot of reasons why
you as a regulated business would want
to you know be on blockchain you should
start looking into it and and so we did
and and you know at the time we already
had the unicorn going we had turned over
a quarter billion unicorns in six months
and you know we're looking at blockchain
from the standpoint of as a regulated
business how can blockchain technology
help us right mm-hmm now imagine we're
dealing with regulators on a regular
basis they they care about things like
AML and kyc you know they care about
responsible gambling where where
customers can have like a full history
of their their bet history you know
imagine putting it on a ledger you know
that there can't be modified and then on
top of that we have this this coin
economy that's going but but even before
the coin economy we're thinking
about how we could use botching to
really help our business but more than
anything how can we use it to to disrupt
banking to circumvent banks like not
about breaking the laws it's more about
circumventing banks which is like an old
archaic system that that you know in in
reality in our business it's it's shitty
like it if you build a really good
blockchain platform there is no better
way to track AML and kyc then through
blockchain on any fiat betting platform
and and so we were convinced you know we
were building we you know and at the
same time we started to pull our
customers about the unit coin and we
said hey you know like we didn't
outwardly say should we turn this into
cryptocurrency we started to ask them
questions like are you familiar with
etherium are you familiar with Bitcoin
you know have you ever traded like on a
wallet and this sort of thing and what
we were what was crazy was 70% of our
customers responded favorably and said
they'd either trading or they were
interested in it you know like because
they're tend to skew younger right so we
knew then look we have a user base
already we know that we can go do this
that's when we created unicorn gold and
and you know coin gold works just like
unicorn silver does except you can take
it off on an exchange however there's a
there's a few things that that's really
unique about it so so customers can
still connect their League of Legends
account or their dota account and they
can earn these coins they earn both gold
and silver coins but you can't just take
the gold coins and then put them on bit
ryx and dump them right you actually
have to turn them over on the platform
so you can use them in jackpots for
skins you can trade skins for coins so
so not only can use them in jackpots for
skins but these skins have real-world
value right people come to our platform
all the time and trade all their skins
for unicorns and then you can also you
know the future when at the time was you
could also bet with them but we treat
our coins like via right so so we treat
it like you know we need a license for
this and and so at the beginning when we
launched the coin it was basically
trading skins for coins entering
jackpots you know doing things that were
like non wagering related and and our
plan was to make it so that you could
bet with the coins on skill and also
spectator games so we started to work on
a license and it took us about a year we
we worked with the Isle of Man and
with Malta and and the isle of man you
know they did a forensic audit on our
token sale they looked at how we handled
kyc on the sale itself how we handled
forensic wallet
you know forensic auditing on the
wallets themselves and we eventually got
a license man we got this is why I've
been sort of buggin you know I just
wanted to tell you that look you know
we're a company that's sitting in
Seattle we can we we have you know we
have a team that's sort of all over the
world we have 93 people in this company
and we just got a license
we're the only put put aside any type of
eSports or whatever we're the only
gambling company in the world with a
license from the Isle of Man for live
betting on sports eSports online casino
and skill right with Fiat and
cryptocurrency they've never given a
license for anyone with cryptocurrency
before and they did it with us because
they saw how we built our platform and
and now we have a license that's awesome
so now we're doing this rollout over you
know across 20 countries it's sort of a
I'd call it a slow rollout because we
just want to make sure that everything
is working and including the US where
we're actually doing a you know a launch
in the u.s. imminently like you know you
know it'll be it'll we'll announce it
within the next two weeks and and it's
going to launch across 41 States we're
launching a certain product across 41
states it's legal in 41 states and and
you'll be able to use unicorn gold as a
betting product in these states that's
awesome congratulations Thanks the it
what you're talking about here reminds
me that I saw an article recently that
said for the first time I think it was
teenagers or young people for Christmas
I was like you know here's what people
are asking for Christmas and both
Bitcoin and fortnight V bucks yeah we're
we're on the list and it was you know
the article is basically saying look
this is one of the first times that this
has happened and it's becoming obvious
that young people want more and more of
these digital assets right well yeah
they don't care about cash
they don't want cash yeah that's right
and and you know I'm guessing that
that's going to continue right I don't
see a reason why it would not and so how
do you you know incorporate that into
the growth plan right so so I'm
fascinated by this idea if if you've got
a user base that will only continue to
grow and then demand will continue to
grow because more people
I'm aware of it people will get older be
replaced by even younger people who are
still interested in this how do you
leverage that interest to actually kind
of put you know rocket fuel on growth
for a company that's in a space that you
know maybe couldn't have existed ten
years ago but now today from a
technology regulation right kind of
consumer interest it's all kind of
coming to a head at the right time well
there's a couple of things so so the
first thing I would say is the the
beauty of the coin or the beauty of
having a coin or a token is you know
we're building a brand around it you
know the idea of you know coin is no
accident right we're we're we're using
it as a foundation for building
community and it's also a great way to
discover new potential applications for
our product like for example there's a
there's a high-end PC company based in
New Jersey they're like they they make
the best pcs in the world they're like
desktop Ferraris so called main gear PC
they they accept unit coin and to to to
purchase their gaming PC's right and and
you know they also started to build
these really cool mining machines that
you know that are just I would describe
it as like the Bugatti of a mining
machine it's just like a
beautiful-looking system and and and
they you know they're creating
applications we run cryptocurrency using
using our coin but also just you know
kind of thinking about crypto in general
as a as sort of a different use cases
and so it's like a neat way for us to
discover interesting use cases there's
other betting products out there the
other companies that are approaching us
who who want to build on blockchain and
don't know how so they want to license
some of our technologies and it's just
it's just a really great way for us to
discover what's coming in the future and
then from a standpoint of virtual goods
there's really the gaming industry is
crazy I mean the skin industry I don't
know how much you know about it but let
me just give you a little bit of insight
as to how big this industry actually got
until at one point there was their skins
and in steam in valve in in a game
called csgo that are super popular and
they have a real world value outside of
the game and the way people purchased
these skins is they buy keys for chests
a key is two dollars and fifty cents and
the chests you open up a chest and
you'll get a skin now some of these
skins are super rare and they trade on a
secondary market because valve create
an API that allowed people to trade
these skins some of these skins man they
sell for $5,000 you know there was a
skin that sold at auction for 60 grand
last year it's it's stupid right and
these are skins that just basically
modify the look of your character in the
game or your weapon in the game and a
couple years ago they there were sites
out there across Eastern Europe in
different places that allowed people to
connect their Steam account to their
platform takes about 10 seconds and then
play games like dice and roulette and
these were all raped games
this became the underpinning of the
largest underage gambling ring in the
history of gambling there was over two
billion dollars turned over in in
illegal gambling with skin betting and
and it was horrible
I mean thirteen year old kids were
getting blown up you know betting on
games that they didn't even know what
they were doing but they were losing all
their skins and eventually valve you
know got got some major heat for it
because effectively their API was
enabling this even though they weren't
behind it they knew that it was kind of
happening and they started to send out
cease and desist to all these different
sites I guess I guess what I'm saying is
that there's that sort of opened up the
opportunity that there is a there is a
market for poor betting in the space but
it needs to be regulated it needs to be
you know 18 or over and that kind of
thing and then and then sorry the second
part I want to say about this is eSports
betting has opened our has opened the
eyes of casino operators how often do
you go to Vegas you go much or I've been
okay so look I go to Vegas all the time
and if you walk through the through the
slot machine area which is the highest
sort of revenue generator for the Las
Vegas casino you'll see more wheelchairs
and walkers per square foot than
anywhere else in the casino right
there's basically one hundred four
hundred and fifty year olds using these
machines and and they tried everything
like they're trying to to to make these
machines more fun for younger people so
they redeem it with Britney Spears and
they put music on it and they have
pitbull and all this stuff and they make
it like it almost like a dance club but
there's still a hundred year olds using
these machines young people hate slot
machines right so so we started to push
on the MGM and other casinos saying look
we you guys should just like move some
of these slot machines out likes let's
set up and he sports lounge and see what
we can do with it and now we actually do
that we actually have an eSports like
area inside of the MGM Grand where it's
like a high-end card room where people
can go in and play for tonight
on Fridays and they can you know they
can they can sort of do a buying
tournament like a card like a card game
right mm-hmm but eventually we see it
where people will be able to go up to a
machine they'll be able to bet on
themselves in that machine and then you
know the the cage just sort of pays them
out we also worked with them on bringing
cryptocurrency onto the strip so it was
interesting we worked with the Nevada
Gaming Commission and we said look we we
just want to use unicorn gold as a means
of incentive and prising in these
tournaments and we actually got approval
for it last year to do it we're the
first you know come first and last I
think company to be able to bring a
cryptocurrency on the strip and you know
we did it in in ng M you know a few
times we ran it a few times and then MGM
sort of wants to kind of evaluate where
this goes but I think crypto in in a
casino has a really really good place
like I think it's a natural fit with the
whole chip economy and things like that
being able to track these chips on the
blockchain you know that sort of thing
just seems like a natural fit and I
think all these guys are really actively
looking at the space they just don't
know how to get in yet
that's awesome yeah what's the biggest
challenge for all of this to come
together men a well know you know you
know as I know right I've seen you on TV
talking about this stuff and it's really
just belief you know like it's so
frustrating like Bitcoin Bitcoin goes
goes up hard and then it comes down hard
right and we've seen it do that multiple
times and we know that it's gonna go up
again and we know that the next bull
market would be bigger than the last
bull market but maybe more focused right
maybe there won't be 2000 coins
maybe they'll be like 200 and that's a
good thing it's like a healthy kind of
you know pruning yeah healthy pruning
and it has to happen the frustrating
part is when you're dealing with sort of
mainstream investors or you know just
like companies like partners things like
that and you're talking about it using
the word crypto is either you're gonna
get different reactions right it's
either gonna be really good or really
bad and and and imagine you're a company
that's sitting at the intersection of
regulated gambling so we're already
dealing in a highly regulated industry
blockchain which is not yet regulated
but they're trying to regulate it they
don't know how to regular
and then you know and then video games
right so we're that's the challenge for
us is we're we're the good thing is
we're comfortable dealing with
regulators and we do it all the time the
bad thing is there's there's still sort
of uncertainty around how to regulate
you know crypto and how to regulate you
know icos and things like that there was
just too many scams last year and it
just made it really hard for companies
like us to sort of emerge right and and
to kind of expose ourselves because if
you look at it if you look at like coin
market cap which I think should be
completely changed but if you look at
coin market cap in youth and you say
let's say the top 100 coins I hate to
say this and I and you know this
probably isn't a very popular opinion
but like I would say 97 maybe 95 percent
of all the coins and the in say the top
2,000 or whatever the two thousand coins
are going to disappear and and five
percent of them or maybe three to five
percent are going to be like stellar
winners but they're but they're buried
underneath a pile of crap and for us
crypto is about being discovered right
it's about like working with an exchange
in in South Korea for example is about
discovery for us right it's about you
know somebody seen our coin and saying
wow what does this company actually do
and and you know versus say speculators
who just want to buy and dump it and
that sort of thing we want users to
discover us and actually use our
platform so there's those are some of
the challenges and then and then the
other challenge is there's a ton of
greed in the space right we we we
believe I believe exchanges are about
discoverability there nothing to do with
access access is a totally different
animal so imagine you are a customer of
unicorn right and you want to bet with
yoona coin gold yes you can earn the
coins on our platform but let's say you
want to bet like a hundred thousand
unicorns on something you want to be
able to acquire those coins so in the
past you'd have to go to coinbase you'd
have to buy some Bitcoin you'd have to
then take your Bitcoin go over to
say--but tracks and then and then
deposit your Bitcoin onto bit drugs and
then from bit recs you'd have to convert
that to ukg and then take it off me like
the experiences are completely stupid
right so we worked with bit tracks which
by the way bit tracks I think is the
best exchange on the planet they are
they are so good because they actually
work with us on the platform itself and
and they helped us build access to our
tokens so
a system where you can actually pay with
credit card come to our website swipe a
credit card buy your tokens right off
the market and it comes right off of
[ __ ] Rex's market it doesn't work in
the u.s. yet but it works outside the US
and around the world and that's about to
me that's about access
so the frustrating part for me is like
many of these exchanges in the last year
were charging massive listing fees to
tokens right and you know as you know
many of these tokens don't even have a
product yet yet they're paying like
hundreds of thousands millions of
dollars for listing fees and now you
know with liquidity the way it is
they're coming back and saying oh by the
way you know your liquidity isn't there
so therefore we want to charge you
market making fees here's our fees from
market making and it's like guys you
know what you're doing is you're
basically stripping out this ecosystem
of any type of innovation at all by
constantly charging for stupid [ __ ]
versus helping them actually instead of
thinking about exchanges and liquidity
you should be think about how do we turn
our exchange into a platform and how do
we help these companies actually build
and innovate so that we have a long-term
business here and you know the fun the
funny thing is as soon as we say no to
that
we got another notice from another large
exchange thing okay well we need we need
large deposits now to protect our
customers like yeah like you know and
that's where I just say like you know
GFS like just it's just like I'm just
done with that you know and and and so
that's why I think there just needs to
be more sort of thought around people
talk about the ecosystem and they care
then they should actually put their
money where their mouth is and start
showing that they care and they want to
help innovate all right before we wrap
up I do quick kind of rapid-fire what's
the most important company in crypto
other than your own I
it sounds biased but I say bit tracks
matrix yeah interesting
definitely anyone's ever say that one
before yeah I'd say bit trucks because
they work with regulators in the US
they're based in the US they are though
I believe one company along with say
coinbase
that's that's working to sort of
legitimize crypto and legitimize you
know blockchain with with huge
implications when you think about things
like you know the the future of the
security token and by the way people
look at they think about security token
they think oh it's just about equity in
a company
and on a token it's not it's way more
than that if you the idea of a
blockchain security token can be it
could be profit sharing in a product it
could be short-term loans it could be
long-term it could be based on real
estate assets could be on a number of
different things and you know these guys
are working actively to legitimize the
idea of a security on a token and and do
it on an ATS some sort of alternative
training system so definitely better X I
think very cool what what is the one
regulation that you would change or
improve if you had a magic wand I can
just wave it well I think I think I
would say that it's not about regulation
as in I want clarity so if I could
change one thing just give us clarity
you know stop telling us to look at laws
from you know a hundred years ago and
trying to apply it to blockchain if you
don't fully understand you know what
what the the products are actually being
built so for us regulatory certainty is
more important than anything else this
is why we're working in Malta
because in Malta they're very crypto
friendly but but I promise you even
though they're crypto friendly doesn't
mean you can just go there and set up a
scam I work with regulators there and
they are hardcore but the nice thing is
you have regulatory certainty so you can
operate and innovate in that type of
environment I worry for the US you know
to be honest I worry that the language
they use sometimes scares people scares
companies who really are trying to build
something right who really want to build
the next generation Internet here in the
u.s. otherwise we're gonna lose like the
the next Twitter the next Facebook the
next Amazon those types of companies
they're gonna end up somewhere in like
friggin Malta which is really stupid
right I mean we really need regulatory
certainty to enable to encourage
innovation here and like safe innovation
and not go out and like use language
that scares you know people into not
wanting to do business here for sure
yeah most important book you've ever
read
hmmm I read a lot of books I think a
brand new deal I really like that one
well it's uh it's it's it's it's
probably a book that no one's read ever
it's it's made by a guy named Scott
Bradbury who basically talked about
brand and I learned a lot about brand
like I learned that a brand is more than
just a logo you put on your t-shirt a
brand is effectively it starts with with
a first of all a great product you have
to have a killer product which is
important but second thing you have to
have is you have to have a great team a
great culture now many companies would
say oh that's that's basic stuff right
the part that they miss is you need a
fanbase
if you create a fanbase then you have
you know people that are gonna carry you
on your back when you're down and out
right if you have those three components
the foundation of it becomes your brand
and I sort of gleaned that from that
book yeah very cool
the only non cryptic question I asked
and then you get asked me a question we
have to admit that aliens are real and
every single time aliens are ever
depicted it's always as a human like
comparison right yeah
obviously we have multiple types of
species here on earth do you think that
there are alien pets or alien animals or
they all just alien humans no I think
that there's I definitely think there's
alien animals I believe there's life
outside of Earth for sure and and I
think it's all kinds of life so yeah do
you think that those aliens I never
asked anybody this before do you think
those aliens are likely to know about us
I think there's probably more advanced
civilizations that know about us yes
absolutely
interesting all right I won't ask you
why you think they haven't contacted us
yet or maybe you think that they have
maybe they have all right we won't go
down that rabbit hole what one question
do you have for me I want to ask you
about Tesla I'm interesting I want you
to tell me what you think the future of
Tesla is in the next five years and I'm
going to tell you what I think the next
five years so I'm gonna cheat and I'm
going to say
I'm gonna remove the time frame sure
right so just what do I think the future
looks like for Tesla I don't have any
kind of inside knowledge I don't really
know anything other than what people
externally have but I will describe a
world I believe can happen right and
I've gotten a lot of heat about this but
I don't think ultimately Tesla is a car
company right I believe it's a power and
energy company I believe that what is
happening that it that a lot of people
are not paying attention to is a
complete disruption of the energy market
and and it's coming at it from a
consumer standpoint so we've had a ton
of different renewable energies and you
know all these different types of energy
sources that are you know supposed to be
clean or better you know all this stuff
what no one's ever been able to do is
figure out how to get the consumer to
demand those better types of energy
right and so the best way to do that is
actually not to sell them energy it's to
sell them a consumer experience that
they want that's better and I'll make
the comparison to the blockchain space a
lot of people argue decentralization is
better than centralization but when you
just go around you say I'm building
let's say the decentralized Facebook
nobody is willing to leave the
centralized Facebook for the
decentralized Facebook just because it's
decentralized exactly you need to build
a 10x better product or more to get them
to switch and you actually don't have to
tell them that it's decentralized chain
know and if you build a better product
people will switch right and whether
it's Facebook you know and any problems
using Facebook as an example and then oh
by the way it happens to be
decentralized it's just an added benefit
yes go back to the Tesla example they've
built a better car yeah right and so
they get people to buy the better car
and oh by the way just happens to be
electric yeah right yeah and so I think
that that's the innovate
and the beauty of what Mosca's done here
is he's convinced people to demand an
energy source right without actually
asking for just the energy source but I
don't I don't I fundamentally do not
believe that most people who are buying
Tesla's actually want Tesla's because
they are electric I think they want
Tesla's because they believe they're a
better car yeah and that's really really
important and so I think that will
continue over time and and I think that
he's gonna hopefully do this cars the
charging network right the the home wall
unit right the the shingles all of these
different things that he can you know
kind of he's already showing if he can
keep changing the consumer demand to
demand the products they think it's
better not just because it's you know
got this energy source I think that he
can fundamentally change the way that we
consume energy I think it's an amazing
it's it's I'm lighting up because you're
saying something that I fundamentally
believe that they're not our company
right and that they are the you know I
think there's an AI neural network part
to it as well you know I don't know if
you've driven one but III I'm a car nut
so I Drive Tesla's and I can tell you
that you know the idea of autopilot and
having other cars on the road is really
interesting I think apples gonna buy
Tesla I think Apple if Apple doesn't buy
Tesla they're in trouble I think Google
will buy them and and I think Tesla
would be better under Google than under
Apple but I think Apple is gonna try
very hard to buy Tesla I think they'll
make Elon Musk the CEO or the chief
visionary and then you know Tim Cook
will do you know something around
operations and you know operational CEO
or something like that Apple needs Tesla
big time they need that type of
innovation back in the company it's just
it's just not the same company as it
used to be it would be wild to see Tim
Cook and Elon Musk cooperating a company
together yeah I don't know if that's
good or bad I have to think about it
more but that would be a that would be a
very interesting world and I wonder if
they could coexist yeah and you know the
idea of Tesla for 20 you know fun
securit is just to me it's cheap I I
just I just cannot believe what's
happened to them in the last year with
the SEC and all the other stuff that
went down but
people underestimate Tesla if they do
they're in trouble
so yeah awesome man thank you so much
for coming this is a lot of fun I
appreciate you you know dropping so much
knowledge about eSports it's a
fascinating industry and that you guys
you didn't cool stuff there yeah thanks
for having me appreciate it